Toussaint Is my Haitian name.
My name is Prince T'Challa,
son of King T'Challa.
Did my mother meet him?
She did.
We agreed
it was better for him to grow up here
away from the pressure of the throne.
But he didn't want us to go to the funeral
because he felt
the time was not yet right.
Your Baba prepared us for his death,
didn't he?
It's nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
Same is a beautiful name.
It holds a great history.
My mom says you're good
at keeping secrets.
Is that true?
Yes. I can keep a good secret.
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charlie Marvel finally release Black
Panther will kind of forever on streaming.
So we'll explain
what's going on with T'Challa son.
The Post-Credits scenes in how they plan
on using the character going forward
as the new version of Black Panther.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're
also doing a giveaway for IMAX tickets
for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania
since that's coming out really soon.
All you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the challenge.
Son Young to Child Prince T'Challa.
Going forward,
Careful for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't seen it yet,
I'm assuming most of you have by now.
But there are a couple of scenes
at the end of the movie,
like Nemours Last scene,
which is a completely separate thing
from the Mid-Credits scene,
which is T'challa's son, Prince T'Challa.
Just to briefly address
the name war scene,
because he will continue
to be a big character in Marvel, Phase
five and beyond.
Like he's the beginning of mutants
popping up in the MCU proper, explaining
why they've been here this whole time,
and we're not seeing them until now.
He's been part of a number of comic book
teams,
like we talk about the Netflix defenders
coming back in the Marvel movies.
Daredevil, Luke Cage,
Jessica Jones, Namor was part
of the original real comic book defenders.
But in the MCU, Nomura questions Why
no more note to the Black Panther Wakanda.
And he claims that they formed a bond.
These are tragic histories,
the loss of their families,
and they're much closer
now, like he's much closer to Shuri.
And eventually
if they wait, like if his people wait,
the surface world, we're comfortable
kinda, which they teased during the movie
because Val's grand plan
is to take all their vibranium.
President wants to take offensive
action against Canada.
What type of
offensive action Destabilization.
When that happens,
he expects Shuri, who's acting as current
Black Panther until T'challa's son
is old enough to turn to them for help.
That's part of the whole vibe
of her version of Black Panther,
is that she's a more stabby
version of the character, a more angry
version of Black Panther,
influenced more by Killmonger.
That's why her Black Panther suit
has more gold highlights in it,
because it's meant to be more showy,
kind of like Killmonger,
but it also looks more stabby
just in general.
Like you might cut yourself
just by touching her.
So the whole idea of a name war
going forward
is that he's still planning his attack
against the surface world.
He's just biding his time,
waiting for wakanda's time of need,
which will probably culminate
around the end of Marvel Phase five.
There's a whole subplot
with Captain America four New World
Order, the Thunderbolts movie,
and they're actually going to be
using team at the Celestial
that's jutting out of the Indian Ocean now
to introduce the MCU version
of Adamantium as well.
So there's a lot of X-Men, Weapon
X, Wolverine Vibranium stuff
that's going to be happening
towards the end of Marvel. Phase five.
I've already done a bunch of separate
videos about that stuff.
Only those in the comments below
during the Mid-Credits scene when we meet
T'challa's son Shuri travels Tanaka's home
in Haiti to spend time with her.
Just chill out.
After things have cooled off,
finally performing their ritual.
What kind of grieving
ceremony on the beach,
burning her funeral garments
from earlier in the movie
when she had tried to do it before
Namor showed up to stop them.
They have a bunch of cool
flashback scenes to T'Challa.
She's remembering him.
It was a cool way
to include him in the movie
without doing some crazy
deepfake situation,
which I feel like would have just made
people really pissed off
when she completes the ceremony,
Nakia brings to call a son to meet her.
His Haitian name is Toussaint,
but his true Wakanda name, as he says,
is Prince T'Challa, son of King T'Challa.
Obviously, they intend him to become
the next Black Panther eventually.
I'll explain the timeline on that, too,
because people are wondering,
are they going to age him up
in like a future movie
or are they going to wait
like ten, 12 years
before we see him again?
Don't worry, it won't be that long.
Marvel does have big plans
for this young T'Challa, and a lot of it
flows with what's happening in the comics
with the Son of Black Panther.
Although in the comics
it's a little bit different.
They've done on the animated series
as well, too.
He does have a son, but it's with Storm,
like he gets married to Storm
in the comics and their son gets both her
mutant powers and Black Panther's powers
and basically becomes like
an X-Men version of the Black Panther.
His name was Azari
and most of the comics that do feature him
are stories from the future
or their movies like Avengers Next,
which take place in the distant future.
I know that a lot of questions
about whether or not this T'Challa
is going to have any natural powers
because the way he was conceived.
I'll talk about that in a second.
But Nakia explains their backstory,
how they can see the child, she explains.
T'Challa told her about his illness,
that he was slowly dying before the snap,
and they made a plan
with her to raise the boy
outside of Wakanda, away from the throne,
just away from the general pressures of
being raised as the Prince originally had.
Chadwick Boseman not died.
A lot of the original story
for what Black Panther was
kind of forever would have been
would have been more of T'Challa
with his son in the movie,
in this whole idea of expectations
in the way
he'd plan to raise his son, as opposed
to the way he was raised by his father.
KING To Shaka.
And what I think they're going to do
is they're going to give what Ryan Coogler
had planned to do for Black Panther.
What kind of forever in T'Challa
storyline to the young T'Challa
and make that like Black Panther three
or Black Panther four just to be real.
I think they're probably going to wait
until like Black Panther four before
we see adult or older version
of young T'Challa here taking the mantle.
Black Panther like Black Panther
three will probably be another Shuri Black
Panther movie.
But the new story for the character
in the current MCU timeline,
T'Challa wanted young T'Challa to have
a normal childhood in their mother.
A reminder had met him.
They had a moment like that
earlier in the movie.
It was kind of a deleted scene,
but they allude to it
when she went to Haiti to meet with Nakia.
Different material. Yes.
We use strictly what we can find here
in Haiti.
You are missed.
We're not.
Gia says that she met the boy.
That's what she was talking about.
She showed up then
and knew about the boy and talked to him.
We just didn't see the scene on screen
because they deleted it.
And because young T'Challa asks sure
if she's good at keeping secrets
and then reveals his true name.
That's just them letting you know that
she won't go back to Wakanda immediately
and tell everybody you like them.
Baku and all the other people actually,
even though they would be overjoyed
at the thought that T'Challa had a child,
they would immediately
want to bring him back to work,
which is exactly what older
T'Challa did not want.
The time is not right.
They're basically saying,
Just wait a couple more movies
before we bring him back in a big way.
Nakia confirms that he was born
after the snap.
She'd already been prepared
for T'Challa to die when he was snapped.
She left before her pregnancy became
so obvious that she was discovered.
She and Koya had a conversation
about that early in the movie.
Like, why did you leave so quickly
after everything went crazy?
But the boy is meant to be about seven,
maybe eight years old.
And Marvel's plan is that in Baku
right now is taking the throne of Wakanda
being the day to day ruler
until young T'Challa is old enough
to beat him in the challenge.
Like they'll do the same thing
that they did
when T'Challa took the Throne
in the first movie.
Once young T'Challa is old enough,
like I said, expecting right now
just based on the way
Marvel's pacing things out.
That'll be around Black Panther four
and that'll be sort of like their soft
reboot of the New line of New Black
Panther taking the mantle
like we made a bunch of Lion King jokes
during the first Black Panther movie
because the plot is very similar
to the Lion King movie.
They'll probably be some light references
and Easter eggs
for that during Black Panther
four or whatever.
That movie winds up
being the circle of life.
And while this is all going out,
like while young T'Challa is growing up
and in Baku is busy with the day to day
ruling of what kind of Shuri is going
to continue to be the Black Panther
and just work on her technology.
What oh, probably wind up happening
though,
is that when they're
putting the young Avengers together,
heading up into Avengers secret words
like we'll see teasers for that.
During Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania,
we probably won't see
the actual young Avengers team
come together in like a real big way
till after Secret Wars.
But I firmly believe right now
that they plan on this young T'Challa
being a member of that young Avengers
while he's younger, teenage
Because I think the whole plan is that
once he does become full Black Panther,
like once he takes the mantle
and takes the throne of Wakanda,
then he would be on the regular Avengers.
But until then, they'll probably cross him
over with the young Avengers
because that's basically what they did
with the Azari character.
I firmly believe had Chadwick
Boseman not passed away,
Marvel would have made him
the centerpiece of the upcoming Marvel
Phase four Marvel. Phase five Marvel.
Phase six Enduring Avengers five Qing
Dynasty, Avengers six Secret Wars.
Black Panther would have been like
one of the big characters
next to people like Spider-Man
and like the main characters of the movie,
even though they're meant
to be giant ensemble films
with billions of characters.
During each saga of movies,
you need to have like a big backbone.
Like Iron Man and Captain America were
the backbones of the Infinity Saga Movies.
Phase one, Phase two. Phase three.
I firmly believe Marvel
had originally intended to center Marvel,
Phase four for Phase five, Phase
six, around the Black Panther character,
Spider-Man two, a couple other
new characters are introducing,
but a lot of the new characters
are just meant to be them
trying new things.
Whereas Black Panther
was meant to be like their sure bet, like,
this is our ringer that we're going
to bring in that everybody loves.
And because Chadwick Boseman did
pass away, they just had to scramble
and figure out a plan B, and their plan
B is to reintroduce the child.
Like they're not recasting,
but they're giving you T'Challa back
just in the form of his son.
It's going to take a little while
for him to age up.
There are a lot of rumors about them doing
a soft reboot of the Marvel Multiverse
universe after Secret Wars,
because that's kind of what happens
during the comic book version
of the more recent Secret Wars,
where they have to rebuild the multiverse,
but they're like a couple minor changes
when they fix everything,
there's a real easy way
how they explain that some X-Men start
popping up on Earth
right after Secret Wars
because they fix things
in a slightly different way.
They can do the same thing
with young T'Challa,
aging him up just a little bit faster
during Avengers five, in Avengers six
because the whole idea is that Avengers
five Qing
Dynasty is sort of like a time travel
based Avengers movie.
It's flat out the easiest way to show you
a future versions of characters, like
the future version of this young T'Challa
who has already become Black Panther.
Early prediction.
We will get a teaser for that
during Avengers five,
and there's this whole conceit
of the Kang Multiverse War
with many different variants they teased
that we would see in the future of Marvel.
People have been wondering
if they're going to do The Iron Lad,
the young version of Kang,
maybe even that's going to be a version
of Riri Williams playing the character,
just pretending to be Riri Williams,
but really it's just another Kang variant.
But what if a young variant of Kang is
pretending to be T'challa's son instead?
Everybody would really flip out
if like a future Black Panther showed up
claiming to be T'challa's
son like I am the young Prince T'Challa.
I have become a king,
but really it's just another Kang variant.
But everyone let me know in the comments
until then.
Like, Well, we still have
the young version of T'Challa.
How do you want them to deal with him
in future movies like Black Panther three?
Do you also want another cameo from him?
Because it sounds like
they're still going to wait
a little bit longer
before they bring him back to Wakanda,
assuming it's going to be three
or four years
before the next Black Panther
movie comes out.
That would put it
after Avengers Secret Wars.
So it would be an easy way to age him up
quite a bit.
We're supposed to get new trailers
for Guardians of the Galaxy three, Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania
in maybe a trailer for the Marvel's movie
Captain Marvel two in a couple TV spots
for Disney Plus series.
We'll see.
I don't know if there's going to be
another Secret Invasion trailer,
whatever they wind up releasing,
of course I'll do videos for it.
Make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for that.
Black Panther Wakanda Forever Deleted
scene in Connections to Secret Invasion
and everyone click here
for my Invincible Season
two trailer video and learn about Jeffrey
Dean.
Morgan Coming
is one of the big villains of the series.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.